monica declares to the various clubs
david presidents of the groups in
parliament and in the present of the pink
no
outr institutions are nights the teams
of the green car vision politics
registration agenda i hate at home
europe's dates back to the cent water promod
oli de jong che raymond ios legislative
priorities for next year  the three
payment of bills on what you told i
in the current year entry offshore
commitment
greiner and also
digitaleurope
l'union that look studio futures
responded citizens expectations
without living che eni
the spanish tease right out this is on
next refer toukam anker powers  satis
nikon omitted stronger from da pandemic
aid space knight frank all member
states forner support and i don't know from adrin
stew source for
cooperation in science that this david
sassoli president of anger in
parliament
thanks president ians thanks to
president von der leyen i
am very happy to  sign the declaration today in the name
of the European Parliament
common on legislative priorities for
2022 during this year we have
faced not only the
devastating effects of the covip pandemic but
also the consequences caused
by climate change from the
unprecedented events and
threats our borders the
european parliament has been
all steps at the forefront
worked together with the council and
committee to urgently approve the
legislation needed to react to the
challenges that have arisen I
therefore consider
interinstitutional cooperation a great success
that has been able to demonstrate the unity of
our institutions
in tackling these challenges and in the
tempo and  political priorities for the
benefit of our citizens we find
the same spirit of cooperation
in this
joint declaration and I am particularly
pleased because it takes up for
2022 for next year the
commitments made in several key political priorities
which are very dear to the parliament
these include the fight for
equal rights is a strengthening of
social europe
and further the fight against climate
change the protection of the rule of
law and our democratic societies
and all necessary measures to
remedy the economic and social
damage caused by the  copit
all these actions to which co-legislators
will prioritize next year
will certainly serve to make
our union more resilient and to
translate our vision of europe into benefits
for the daily life of our
citizens
this joint declaration goes in this
direction
together we will certainly continue to
work  throughout 2022 to
make sure that the commitments we
signed today are
implemented and respected
thanks for your cooperation
I
too sport presented therapy with no
fund to the other
in short
like to thank you
expression
of
course
veneti state therefore the
nations and white  sands
of
european
d  eclaration
[Applause]
and here
well
how many
[Music]
no